you're a wizard harry
i'm a what the harry potter film
franchise ruled the box office for a
decade but it also managed the uncommon
feat of earning certified fresh status
for every single one of its installments
it remains one of the most successful
movie sagas of all time and it's even
spawned a spin-off series
right on your hop
oh
here's some attachment issues
but while the first fantastic beasts
continue the certified fresh streak the
second became the first rotten entry in
the cinematic wizarding world so as we
prepare for a third film set for a 2022
release we're ranking all harry potter
movies by tomato meter
[Music]
starting with number 10 fantastic beasts
the crimes of grindelwald
in an effort to thwart grindelwald's
plans of raising pure blood wizards to
rule all over non-magical beings albus
dumbledore enlists his former student
newt scamander unaware of the dangers
that lie ahead lines are drawn as love
and loyalty are tested even among the
truest friends and family in an
increasingly divided wizarding world
starring eddie redmayne katherine
waterston johnny depp and directed by
david yates critics say fantastic beasts
the crimes of grindelwald has glimmers
of the magic familiar to harry potter
fans but the story spell isn't as strong
as earlier installments
no more silver tongue
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
uh
me
[Music]
uh
number nine fantastic beasts and where
to find them the year is 1926 and newt's
commander has just completed a global
excursion to find and document an
extraordinary array of magical creatures
arriving in new york for a brief
stopover newt might have come and gone
without incident were it not for a few
things a nomad named jacob a misplaced
magical case and the escape of some of
newt's fantastic beasts spell trouble
for both the wizarding and no-maj worlds
starring eddie redmayne katherine
waterson colin farrell and directed by
david yates critics say fantastic beasts
and where to find them draws on harry
potter's rich mythology to deliver
spin-off that dazzles with franchise
building magic all its own
[Music]
oh excuse me
everyone settle down
stay dougal don't come in there
don't let me come down there
absolutely not
i love
oh so you're gonna steal the money huh
terrific is totalis
used to be
really
no
flick
[Music]
oh no
no no
no don't shoot don't shout
god for the last time you pilfering pest
pause off what doesn't belong to you
hopefully sorry about that
number eight harry potter and the
deathly hallows part one without the
guidance and protection of their
professors harry ron and hermione begin
a mission to destroy the horcruxes the
sources of voldemort's immortality
though they must rely on one another
more than ever dark forces threatened to
tear them apart voldemort's death eaters
have seized control of the ministry of
magic and hogwarts and they're searching
for harry even as he and his friends
prepare for the ultimate showdown
starring daniel radcliffe emma watson
rupert grint and directed by david yates
critics say it can't help but feel like
the prelude it is but deadly hollows
part 1 is a beautifully filmed
emotionally satisfying penultimate
installment for the harry potter series
mary
go home
get the kids
i'll meet you there we have to get out
the country understand
mary do as i say
mary
who's that
long story
nice meeting you it's harry potter it's
harry
harry potter
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
hmm
number seven harry potter in the order
of the phoenix
now in his fifth year at hogwarts harry
learns that many in the wizarding
community do not know the truth of his
encounter with lord voldemort cornelius
fudge minister of magic appoints his
toadie dolores umbridge as defense
against the dark arts teacher for he
fears that dumbledore will take his job
but her teaching is deficient and her
method's cruel so harry prepares a group
of students to defend the school against
a rising tide of evil starring daniel
radcliffe imelda staunton gary oldman
and directed by david yates critics say
it is not easy to take the longest harry
potter book and streamline it into the
shortest hp movie but director david
yates does a bang-up job of it creating
an order of the phoenix that's
entertaining and action-packed
uh
me
oh
[Music]
uh
number six harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone
the first adaptation of jk rowling's
popular children's novels about harry
potter a boy who learns on his 11th
birthday that he is the orphan son of
two powerful wizards and possesses
unique magical powers of his own he is
summoned from his life as an unwanted
child to become a student at hogwarts in
english boarding school for wizards
there he meets several friends who
become his closest allies and help him
discover the truth about his parents
mysterious deaths starring daniel
radcliffe emma watson rupert grint and
directed by chris columbus critics say
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
adapted source material faithfully while
condensing the novel's overstuffed
narrative into an involving and often
downright exciting big screen magical
caper
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
hi
pride
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hurry up swish and flick
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
number five harry potter and the chamber
of secrets the follow-up to harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone finds young
wizard harry potter and his friends
facing new challenges during their
second year at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry as they try to
discover a dark force that is
terrorizing the school starring daniel
radcliffe kenneth branagh robbie
coltrane and directed by chris columbus
critics say though perhaps more
enchanting for younger audiences chamber
of secrets is nevertheless both darker
and livelier than its predecessor
expanding and improving upon the first
film's universe
might i suggest someone from my own
house
malphite
perhaps
good luck potter thank you sir
[Music]
one's at the ready
[Music]
scared potter
you wish
on the count of three
cast your charms to disarm your opponent
only to disarm we don't want any
accidents here
one
two three
[Music]
richter sempra
i said disarm only
seven sortier
don't move potter
i'll get rid of it for you allow me
professor snape
volati ascendante
[Music]
number four harry potter and the half
blood prince
as death eaters wreak havoc in both
muggle and wizard worlds hogwarts is no
longer a safe haven for students though
harry suspects there are new dangers
lurking within the castle walls
dumbledore is more intent than ever on
preparing the young wizard for the final
battle with voldemort meanwhile teenage
hormones run rampant through hogwarts
presenting a different sort of danger
love may be in the air but tragedy looms
and hogwarts may never be the same again
starring daniel radcliffe michael gambin
tom felton and directed by david yates
critics say dark thrilling and
occasionally quite funny harry potter
and the half blood prince is also
visually stunning and emotionally
satisfying
keepers need to be quick agile
i like my chances
say um i think you could introduce me to
your friend granger
wouldn't mind
getting on a first name basis know what
i mean
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
us
wow
[Music]
number three harry potter and the goblet
of fire
the fourth movie in the harry potter
franchise sees harry returning for his
fourth year at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry along with his
friends ron and hermione there is an
upcoming tournament between the three
major schools of magic with one
participant selected from each school by
the goblet of fire when harry's name is
drawn even though he is not eligible he
must compete in the dangerous contest
starring daniel radcliffe robert
pattinson rafe finds and directed by
mike newell critics say the main
characters are maturing and the
filmmakers are likewise improving on
their craft vibrant special effects and
assured performances add up to what is
the most complex yet of the harry potter
films
have it your way
[Music]
do nothing to finish
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when the connection is broken you must
get to the poll key
we can leave it for a moment to give you
some time but only a moment do you
understand
take my body back will you
take my body back to my father
let go
sweetheart you're ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
number two harry potter and the prisoner
of azkaban
harry potter's third year at hogwarts
starts off badly when he learns deranged
killer sirius black has escaped from
azkaban prison and is bent on murdering
the teenage wizard while hermione's cat
torments ron's sickly rat causing a rift
among the trio a swarm of nasty
dementors is sent to protect the school
from black a mysterious new teacher
helps harry learn to defend himself but
what is his secret tie to sirius black
starring daniel radcliffe emma watson
gary oldman and directed by alfonso
cuaron critics say under the assured
direction of alfonso cuaron harry potter
and the prisoner of azkaban triumphantly
strikes a delicate balance between
technical wizardry and complex
storytelling
[Music]
[Music]
come on
move
ugh
uh
[Music]
happy
[Music]
oh i'm sorry
don't worry
and finally number one harry potter and
the deathly hallows part two
a clash between good and evil awaits as
young harry ron and hermione prepare for
a final battle against lord voldemort
harry is grown into a steely lad on a
mission to rid the world of evil the
friends must search for the horcruxes
that keep the dastardly wizard immortal
harry and voldemort meet at hogwarts
castle for an epic showdown where the
forces of darkness may finally meet
their match starring daniel radcliffe
ray finds alan rickman and directed by
david yates critics say thrilling
powerfully acted and visually dazzling
deathly hallows part 2 brings the harry
potter franchise to a satisfying and
suitably magical conclusion
if anyone here
has any knowledge
of mr potter's movements this evening
i invite them to step forward
now
it seems despite your exhaustive
defensive strategies you still have a
bit of a security problem headmaster
i'm afraid it's quite extensive
how dare you stand where he stood
tell them how it happened that night
tell them how you looked him in the eye
a man who trusted you and killed him
tell them
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well muggles that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the ron
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
for even more new scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com until next time i'm
your host naz perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you